are you ready to hear the challenge I'm
super ready I'm just visualizing the
board and
she's following the rules she's got the
pieces in the middle of the squares I'm
following
yep now uh I don't know what the
official rules are on weighted pieces
but being a WF fan yeah
that was a little trick and that
probably cost her a good half second but
that's gonna help the viewer beats you
got it true okay now all of these pieces
are good oh my God your scarf is not
helping uh neither by the way another
queen are also not helping is the 40
degree temperature and for all you
Europeans that's like five okay okay
okay
all right you might need to fix the pawn
on E2 and F7 but you know you're getting
there
okay so we'll take the Queens out for
the next attempt something I had not to
fix up seven fix up seven
54.5 seconds
but awesome job